hey how's it goin rez - welcome back to
South Park stick of truth' dick of jus
wait name douchebag you here and we are
ready to head on on our next adventure
we have three new quests let's check the
map okay so we need to go here so where
do we go South Park
it's really cool to actually be walking
inside the game okay everybody that's
but Brady right you gotta love the music
- man [ __ ] snowballs what are they
doing that up in there I saw two rats
running around last time I was at
skaters bar I'll probably still eat
there slow
car begin es Willian that public
bathroom over they went Jen okay thank
you for sharing butters that oh it's him
haha we must get back to the question
hand by the word come play hide-and-seek
with us you're at what new quest
hide-and-seek I don't want to do side
quest come on there's a room of the
girls have a secret base but I've never
seen it playing pirate is better than
being a parent who is he living stick it
with Somali idiot oh there's Ike oh [ __ ]
we got to fight them kindergarteners
okay I guess we can murder them oh oh
they're not too bad
holy [ __ ] alright pour a little
kindergarteners it this little beard
I guess that molestation joke is too far
when there's little kids I don't know
what I'm supposed to do here oh [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] that was awesome
finishing butters hey you're a [ __ ]
that's why what what what the hell is
finishing with some good old jujitsu I
don't know what I'm doing but I like it
but if use your JAMA of justice I just
will see if it works
so bad at all babe a taboo bamm-bamm
oh no she ran off I don't care baby by
the stalled I get the bearded man no
what is that
why did they get the cannons from where
where are they all right it's finishing
in tired of this I really feel really
sad for them 580 XP girl let's check her
can we level up or some [ __ ] I can wear
a blunt wig nice nice
now people won't be bothered with my
ugly hair yeah what the hell are you
doing oh yeah we're looking at and
seeing I forgot about that
alright find you I really don't care
okay uh we need to go up there this is
complicated map [ __ ] I I'm not really
used to it we can have a double chin now
[ __ ] that it I my butt cheeks are the
best seconds are gonna be a lot of
walking involved when you don't know
like all the fast travel I hit it's here
it's here finally okay is this billing
tweaked bros oh my god it's our coffee
hi guy could bros welcome to tweet
coffee coffee made with ingredients
supplied by local organic suppliers it's
local coffee brewed locally twig twig oh
you picked up the fresh local
ingredients
I'm still trying to do on my charge well
hurry up son the family business is
relying on you ah poor tweek oh man I
forgot about him you should try some
coffee it gives you that edge you need
to stay focused at school
all right you know that meme like a step
one blah blah blah step two above law
step 3
except for profit that's where the Tweed
episode I remember there yes he's so
awesome now you know the Wii me way too
much to do wait you get the 4 o'clock
delivery for me if you do I can finish
here and them and then I'll still have
time to play please would you
it's a Kenny's house like always you
give them this he'll give you the
delivery my god damn it how am I
supposed to do all of this there's no
way man Starbucks has like eight
employees it's just me yeah oh my god
it's me when I make a videos alright um
can you keep a secret
you can I this game is really detailed
you gotta appreciate it for that man a
detailed game is a good game man I keep
saying man man okay so now we need to go
shut up again Oh Lexi
so I can go here now maybe it's this way
yeah it's this way okay excellent
uh-huh another faster I was awesome
thank God for that thing not god more
homeless people what do they want
oh yeah kidneys poor I forgot what oh
this isn't for me this is for the nice
people who are written the guesthouse
out in the back
best winning pose armor again what are
you doing stop being a lizard this is
the guest house the garage I think so
yes of course are the nice people yeah
yeah we got the package for tweet coffee
you got the envelope these witch doctors
must be cooking up a secret potion one
of its a healing potion probably and it
smells like it here you go take it hey
that's not the usual kid it picks up the
package huh oh [ __ ] it's a kid is your
kid so we're gonna have to fight mad
people right um all right let's fling
our own David these [ __ ] can that
[ __ ] always works really well this cops
crazy how can you think ah okay let's
finish him with hammer of justice that
was the most perfect throw ever see
that's what you get for trying to mimic
Walter oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] man hi I'm gonna
keep trying to nuke them gets me up
right in the [ __ ] if her [ __ ] was her
leg great Oh bonus holy damage
get this one yeah yeah oh that was close
indeed lettuce Oh [ __ ] sake let's go
let's kill him I think that's my bird
that does life on this I'd really don't
but they died very pretty look at this I
think so this one has nice tits
okay we go up here wife cause go away
whoa easy it is a little confusing but I
like it okay it's just cuz I'm not used
to it there it is holy [ __ ] I'm dumb
okay return back to tweak for the tweet
the Tweaker got it so much tweaking
alright we're back at the coffee shop
hello gentlemen is anything I can do for
you can I go play where's today's
delivery right here hmm yep that's good
[ __ ]
alright tweek you can play for a little
bit but be home before dark or you'll be
grounded grounded like the fresh grinds
of our all-organic tweek blend made with
ingredients from local tweakers okay I
gotta go get changed then I'll beat you
at the kingdom
seven friends Wow
I'm gonna be rich all right I'm gonna
have to take a break here alright I'm
back it's been a day actually holy [ __ ]
who would have thought alright so next
up on our list is to find another one of
the friends we have token here token is
the rich black guy and I liked know what
hi
over here I did not expect this alright
work I'm not here to hurt you
is it me Al Gore you know Al Gore I'm
super important
all right look I've detected some very
strange activity in this area I believe
we are dealing with manbearpig Josh team
and Irma I know you're scared but I need
help take these and place them in the
location specified on the man-bear map
and now I'm going to make you my friend
on Facebook no very prestigious you have
my email now but don't give it out to
anybody i'm super-cereal
hurry we must know if member peg is here
or not
the immerser member olace keeps saying
i'm super-cereal that's from the
manbearpig episode actually it's funny
how much so you guys I hate that [ __ ]
is that a tiny Stephano it's funny how
much South Park you're probably
influenced people and meet me at least
so we'll do the manbearpig later but I
want to do the friends quiz now all
right let's get to this rich
[ __ ] gated community sir we do
not allow in the riffraff move along sir
the help
if you try again I will pepper spray you
back to the Stone Age I could swear I
heard a voice coming up from the sewers
it said something like holy hell even oh
my god like I'm realizing like beautify
that's from howdy how folks the way I
said it holy [ __ ] South Park really
[ __ ] changed me man
this is not good we got a new message
from Cartman I realize also this is like
Facebook or whatever okay Cartman haha
dude someone just posted a video of you
getting pepper spray hold on I gotta
watch that again how high it's even
better than when you know what it's
what's coming butters and butters did
you like the [ __ ] video you're
[ __ ] sorry about that
where's something to protect yourself
from the security this guard pepper
spraying all right
so that's what we have to do I think I
know we can go shopping somewhere we can
go inside the Rhino pies me about your
hair how are you
you [ __ ] Hey
thank you so much oh hello are you
interested in some rhinoplasty he's like
so I can change I can get hassle huh oh
my God we're gonna stay for the
Hasselhoff
it's the Chinese woman again I see look
wicked faith pain okay cool here's
glasses we have to get cool ones skin
okay
I'll add you to our email list sometimes
we do two-for-one specials okay your
city wok serving Mongolian food now
was that you and it was David I promise
so that worked out surprisingly a lot
better than I thought awesome I think
there's a secret behind here excellent
doing great press prouder yeah I feel
like these are the most Jewish ones so
let's wear them sir I'm a professional
[ __ ] you bring it if you try again I
will pepper spray you that could have
went better I could have gone a little
better all right let's check over here
that has to be something hi Jim Bo's
guns nice she did well what brings you
here today
business or pleasure or vengeance Lynn
James look under the right place that
guy was my favorite when I was a kid I
don't even know why all night she has a
nice leg there it's coming right for us
let me buy some my way haven't seen you
before you must be the new kid that
moved to town and you're into hunting
huh well my boy you've come to the right
place South Park has chock-full of
things to shoot that would delight any
taxidermist survivalist or weekend
animal death enthusiast ain't much I
could sell to a minor a mushy Zelda
minor well he can't say oh that's
perfect we got a guy as me thank you sir
that was quite my pleasure David barking
spider look out he did he just described
Jaime okay like that okay well I prefer
to my yata milk but I guess it allowed
you do
[ __ ] this [ __ ] man holy [ __ ] what the
[ __ ]
oh no and even like oh I can't wait to
eat this pocket in for you okay this is
sling adamian oh oh [ __ ] has a lot of
health but it no that's that one man is
use your butter batter I'm sorry
ooh nice block better sling of David
again man oh oh no don't taste putters
poor butters no one likes him oh yeah no
[ __ ] he's tough but it's not that tough
Oh
finish him butters finish him with your
hammer
come on butter's oh [ __ ] hell all of
that oh god watch face did we get him
now we did you oh we got Billy's clever
smiling that's my favorite
I really like my Jewish staff but I do
think if it's better than we're gonna
have to it's a level 2 all right we're
back we're back
all this pretend it's a dildo now let's
[ __ ] find token already yeah damn
what yeah that was fast
haha can I help you
what's this Oh yells dipstick again hang
on a second
what thank you for that message trailer
I shall make haste to coop Aki mom can
you drive me to Eric's house [ __ ] yeah
I love the little plastic knives that he
had taped on him that was a lot of work
for that quake and Lee doodle a nicer if
I push it which is a taco of course
using their now [ __ ] [ __ ] he's
looking at me yeah that's right maybe
you should see a doctor
why don't tell me what did oh okay uh
Nexus banners all right here it is
you're looking for Craig Yee he can't
play he's in detention
something about flipping off the
principal oh no Craig's in jail we gotta
go tell the Grand Wizard does it look
like I give a [ __ ] all right so we have
to go to Cartman here we go so Jewish
reporting for duty Craig dude nice work
douchebag now all my men are here and
ready to fight for it wait a minute
where's feldspar where's my level 12
thief hey hey yeah well where's Craig
he's in detention what he flipped off
the principal so even detention again oh
my god if they've locked away our
thief's in detention we have no hope of
getting back to stick of truth we have
to break him out ah no way man well then
we broke Craig out of detention we all
got in trouble getting into trouble is a
risk that douche bag is willing to take
you have to break out our thief douche
bag but don't worry I will not let you
go and prepared I'm going to teach you
how to use magic meet me at the training
barracks it's time for you to learn
dragon shout oh very scare him huh level
three
hell yeah all right let's level up we
can now wear a bun wig why the [ __ ]
would I wear that [ __ ] this is my way
prettier all right teach me magic fight
well douchebag but the true
succeed in combat you must learn to
harness the power of your fight
Oh farting on the opponent precisely the
right time is key battle I shall show
you how it's done
but first you must take the gentleman's
hood you must promise to never ever fart
on any one spot okay farting on an
opponent is necessary but farting on
someone's bowels is not true you
understand right there let's begin your
training the conjurer dragon chef you
must first clear your mind and take in a
deep breath through your butthole like
so oh [ __ ] let it bubble inside you and
dragon shout I'll show you one more time
suck it in remember dragon job
now you ready drag it out I don't know
if I'm ready for this find a frequency
herd herd holy [ __ ]
a man could live a hundred years and
never again witness a spell so
boisterous could it be that the
prophecies are true could it be that the
dragon bone has come at last in our hour
of need
now let us try your skill on a real
opponent Hey hey princess Kenny
could you come here a sec okay okay real
quick crazy skinny so juicy I want to
show you something
all right you two spot sergers back sho
fingers Kenny the magical powers eyes on
you I don't know Kenny okay [ __ ]
hilarious
that was [ __ ] awesome oh okay good
jock juice bag oh sweet thanks pretty
skinny that's all for now okay but dude
seriously remember don't ever do that on
someone's balls okay seriously you have
master dragon chefs but now on it will
be easier for you so this game is like I
missed you on your quest douchebag now
go get Craig while I rest and relax upon
my throne on your throne huh
cool so Kenny will go with us now
like a the game is like a mishmash of
loading sky raving all these [ __ ]
things Game of Thrones and that's really
cool rock insanity
pull the wishin I just want to say I
think it's so cool to be playing this
game for you bros I really really love
it I hope you bros loved it as well
thank you for watching I see you in the
next episode if you want to leave a like
or do what I would show your support I
really do appreciate it and and like I
said it it helps to keep the series more
alive and it's awesome you're awesome
for doing it so here's a brofist for you
seeing the next one tomorrow